alex jones ordered to pay
45.2 million dollars in punitive damages
to sandy hook parents
let's get some important context here
real quick though
this is from abovethelaw.com
texas damages cap looms over alex jones
sandy hook defamation case they
basically lay it out the family wants
150 million they've awarded 45 but this
is where it's interesting they say here
others have pointed out the texas law
caps punitive damages at twice the
compensatory damage award plus seven
hundred fifty thousand
moreover an exemplary damage award
requires a uh an and unanimous a
unanimous jury and only ten of the
twelve jurors agreed on the original 4.1
million compensatory award and if the
jury's original award was for
non-economic damages i.e to compensate
for the pain and suffering they may only
get the 750 000 in this phase of the
trial which is perhaps why plaintiff's
council tried to anchor the jury at 150
million dollars in the first place so it
looks like all in all alex jones will
end up being on the hook for about 13
million dollars they say texas law
prohibits telling the jury about the cap
so it may well return a massive verdict
which will then be reduced to comply
with the statute sending a signal about
jones's moral culpability but allowing
him to walk away with a slap on the
wrist in light of the company's annual
revenues in the neighborhood of 65
million
interesting thing here is
this is what uh me let me read here let
me read you what the lawyer said
quote
i ask that with your verdict you not
only take alex jones's platform that he
talks about away i ask that you make
sure that he can't rebuild the platform
that's what matters lawyer wesley ball
said that is punishment that is
deterrence um no that's execution
punishment is like we're going to make
you pay a lot of money and you're going
to learn how to do this again what he's
talking about is completely destroying
alex jones and everybody who works for
him so
that's it there it is this is what
everybody assumed this was all about
alex jones was uh was it was a default
judgment he wasn't allowed to defend
himself
they claim and uh may be correct that he
did not comply with discovery alex jones
claims he did
it's a crazy story man what freaks me
out is that they just nuked his company
i mean i i think in my opinion jones
probably has a ton of cash because he's
been doing this for a long time and i'd
be willing to bet he hid a lot of it why
wouldn't he have but it looks like
they're just trying to destroy as much
of this company as possible especially
with 2024 coming up and trump probably
running again yeah i feel like when
you're as uh
financially successful as alex jones is
you know well in advance to set up
systems that will protect your money i
mean it's not like he's just sticking i
mean maybe he is but he's probably not
sticking the cash in the walls of his
house it's it's hidden under tax
shelters or in trust i mean not that i
could fault him or anyone else for doing
that why would you leave that much cash
vulnerable yeah
this is why people set up llc's for like
everything you ever notice this for
people who are renting you may notice
you're paying rent to like your address
yeah like if you live at 123 fake street
you write a rent check to 123 fake
street llc and then you mail it in
because
they want to limit the liability you
slip and fall in that house you sue them
they only got that one house in that
company but the people who own that
house they probably own 50 houses all
under their own llcs yep or basic things
you put your money in a trust or a
series of protected trusts or blind
trusts and then they're not
you when you co even if you get this
damage you can't excuse those trusts how
does how how would that work how does a
can you explain like how a trust would
work look just because i went to law
school i don't
know anything about
distance himself from his past
all right so so basically what a trust
is
is it's like it's almost imagine like a
corporation but it doesn't have a job to
do other than
uh be a vehicle for money so like i have
a trust in my uh we have a max family
trust and uh like most of my assets are
in the max family trust and my wife and
i are the executors of the trust and our
children other beneficiaries right so if
i were to like
get drunk and drive like an idiot and do
something stupid and hurt somebody and
they sue me and win they can't seize the
trust right they can only seize my
personal assets you know i have a few
cars whatever we have some nonsense but
there's not a whole lot you can take
um and it's a way of protecting assets
but from
basically from seizure
is there a risk
i mean yeah there's a few but not really
like uh
what's a risk a risk is my wife and i
could get divorced and the way we have
our trust set up is not like super well
situated for that that possibility and
then um
i mean if i live a long time there's
certain things i can't do with the
assets and that trust because they're in
a trust like i can't just
um
i can't unilaterally decide i'm going to
sell my property because my wife is an
executor as well so we both have to
decide what if it was a single like
single member yeah well then it depends
on the trust right so like uh um you
can't just say okay my stuff's in a
trust and so no one can sue me like you
have there's certain legal structures
you have to go through like uh there's
so many different trusts blind trust
irrevocable trust spent thrift trust it
just depends on what you're doing and
certain ones are protected from certain
legal liabilities some are not some are
protected from almost all it really just
depends it seems seems crazy though i
mean if that's the case then why
wouldn't alex jones just be like here's
300 million dollars
like i don't alex seems kind of crazy to
me so maybe he has or hasn't but most
people i know who have serious money
like you get into the eight figures and
above then you start protecting your
assets and things like that yeah yeah
isn't there some wasn't there i don't
he's been in a couple lawsuits related
to sandy hook and if i'm remembering
correctly at one point they were arguing
that he financially benefited off of the
suffering that he put like the family
and parents through by promoting
conspiracy theory or whatever as a claim
was so part of it is like
i remember
and i hate to quote this because i don't
have something in front of me to
reference but he um
he had they had wanted him to say
basically how much money he had made
during that time period because it
gained him he was well known but it was
one of the things that really uh gave
him a certain amount of notoriety and
that turned into financial benefit and
so therefore the argument would be and i
believe is that the family is actually
entitled to this profit because he made
it unfairly off of that right right
right so he in some ways he wants to
hide i'm not saying he does but like he
would want to hide his money
if that were true i'm not and i'm i
don't want to imply you're a financial
expert right but if you had a trust like
this could could there be like a bank
account with just cash in it you could
pull money out whenever you wanted
uh you can set up trust like that
totally yeah it's not that hard because
like you know first when i heard that
they were getting going after him for
four million dollars i was like
alex jones is worth a lot he can easily
cover for i know he has at least two
kids right yeah yeah like i know he has
kids so like if he has any sense at all
or anyone around him has sense he has
trust set up probably individually for
the kids and then family trusts and
that's just one way to shelter money
there's a lot of other ways like you
know you you panama
well yeah panama papers
right i don't think he's operating at
that level like those tended to be
serious serious wealth um uh but you
there's plenty places you can buy
property um dude just the state of texas
it's really hard to seize
bankruptcy either seize assets in a
bankruptcy or from a legal judgment it's
very there's a lot of weird rules in
texas it's really hard this is why i see
this and they're like you know the
lawyer says make sure he can't rebuild
his company i'm like there's literally
nothing you can do that's just posturing
i'm pretty sure i think you know some
people have claimed i saw people
tweeting that uh they're filming a
documentary about it or whatever so
everything's really hammed up
but i'm like
even if alex jones
every last penny was taken from him some
random guy will walk up on the street
with a cell phone and film alex jones
ranting and it'll get millions of views
like just you can't take that away from
somebody no no social capital
invaluable or and just the ability that
he has whatever it may be i mean
the dude yells and people watch he's
already an established name i mean
people know him maybe if you had cut him
off years and years and years ago he
wouldn't have the kind of influence that
he has today but that's just really not
the case he's an established brand with
or without the company yeah and i i also
don't know if you could ever have cut
him off it's just like the kind of guy
he is he's he's a he's a he's a bull
charging through he's gonna
he was my understanding from people who
know him he was like that in high school
like that's just no really he used to
walk around the halls like yelling about
injustice of some whatever was the thing
at the time like yeah he he's just one
of those dudes
yeah they clearly don't like him so i
guess the the conspiracy theory as it
were
i i don't even know if you can call it a
theory or a conspiracy or whatever but
the idea is that
all of this is just to find the
vulnerability in infowars to
knock the whole thing down people have
left the company because of uh stuff
like this but i i think to be fair i
mean the dude defamed private
individuals and this is what happens i
mean i remember when he was talking
about that i'm like dude what are you
like yeah there's things that you can
make the false flag claim on i don't
think this is it
this is not a hill to plant your flag
i guess you know what i guess the
argument they're making is that it was
working for him it was getting the
clicks and people were eating it up
there were people at the company telling
him to stop it wasn't worth it now
apparently there's like two more
defamation suits that are coming up yeah
from this from sandy hook families yeah
yeah i don't think it's going to stop
i mean
look i i understand why the families
would be pissed you know or was that
some fall over yeah i totally just
kicked the truck throwing stuff
like i don't you know with kyle
rittenhouse i said this i'm like look
man
you know
i'm gonna give anybody the same uh
benefit of the doubt initially i don't
care if you're walter cronkite or if
you're alex jones or whatever and then
you know i'll i'll when you say
something i'll fact check it that's all
that matters i'm not here to play these
these like who do i like who i don't
like games
but uh
yeah i don't know man
it's very clear that when you look at
i'll be careful how i say this
what people are saying about the court
case they don't care whether alex jones
is telling the truth whether he's lying
they just hate him they want him gone i
think he's like a mythical figure at
this point to a lot of people like he is
this symbol of all the horrible dark
corners of the internet that they're
afraid of and supposed to stay away from
and you know that may not be exactly who
alex is but they see it as sort of this
righteous victory over him because he is
a representation of a larger problem
with society thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you